bonjour morgan dalle bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france
alors on a entendu il ya quelques jours
emmanuel macron donner une date possible
de réouverture le 21 juin sauf que ça a
été démenti derrière par par ses
conseillers on parle plutôt d'une 2
juillet actuellement les négociations
sont en cours
sur quoi porte tel ces négociations
actuellement
alors tout d'abord voilà comme vous le
rappelez ça a été démenti et acer que à
l'heure actuelle où je vous parle il n'y
a toujours pas de date rouverture ou de
décrets de couverture pour les disques
hockey pour les discothèques pardon nous
attendions à une clause de revoyure au
15 juin
on leur a plutôt le 20 juin bon je vous
cache pas que l'on trouve que c'est un
peu de mauvais goût parce que le jour de
la fête de la musique où tout toute la
france sur une discothèque géante les
discothèques seront encore serre mais
ensuite on a entendu au travers de
différents médias il serait peut-être
possible d'ouvrir avec un protocole
sanitaire à 6k passe sanitaires il est
utile de rappeler que le conseil d'état
lors de sa décision il ya 15 jours parce
que les discothèques l'avait saisie
avait bien averti sur le fait qu'il ne
devrait avoir aucune rupture d'égalité
entre les discothèques et les autres
professions pouvant exercer la même
profession car si on parle pas
sanitaires il faudra ce ne sera pas
viable économiquement ya pas besoin
d'être économiste pour se douter que
économiquement avec seulement la moitié
de la population vaccinée dans cette
moitié de population vaccinée seulement
30% des jeunes sont vaccinés il n'y aura
pas foule aux boîtes d aux portes des
discothèques
ensuite ça portera il y aura un problème
d'équité entre les différents traits
différents commerces activités
car comment justifier une ouverture à
kpass sanitaires pour une salle qui est
à 100 mètres d'une discothèque ou pour
ou pour un bar ambiance musicale qui
n'aura pas ou qu'on soit là ce sera à
justifiable donc ouvrir de cette façon
ce sera contre productif
on ne pourra pas cumuler 2 après en ce
qui concerne le protocole
on est sûr c'est des batailles de
chiffres c'est à dire c'est on nous
propose un certain pourcentage
nous on aimerait forcément ouvrir avec
le maximum de capacité possible tout en
pouvant assurer la sécurité sanitaire de
nos clients mais il est important de
rappeler que si les discothèques ne
rouvriront pas ne rouvre pas cet été ça
posera un gros problème de sécurité dans
nos centres villes sur nos littoraux et
sur les lieux de villégiature et que nos
mères ont besoin des discothèques
car ils n'en peuvent plus c'est à dire
que même en ayant un couvre-feu à 21h
les les centre-villes l'élite aurait
lieu
oui auparavant déjà à dire quelques
jours déjà les mères n'en pouvez plus on
a vu des articles dans la presse
régionale ou les mères n'en pouvait plus
et là on s'apprête à cause des fêtes
sauvages car non c'est ça hein
bah ouais exactement que des fêtes
sauvages à cause des nuisances nocturnes
les mères n'en pouvais plus été saisi
tous les matins par par leurs
concitoyens
il n'en pouvait plus et là 23h désormais
c'est égal c'est les forces de sécurité
qui tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
attention sans soupape pour les jeunes
c'est un été de tous les dangers
sans parler d'une éventuelle quatrième
bac a plus personne n'en parle sauf une
petite une petite minorité
d'épidémiologistes mais il reste encore
ce petit risque d'une quatrième vague ou
si la jeunesse non vaccinés n'est pas
encadré alors ce sera un potentiel
risque de propagation au travers de
cette jeunesse
alors on parle d'un protocole très
strict vous l'avez dit avec même d'aider
des personnes qui auraient vérifié que
ces mesures soient bien appliquées dans
les discothèques ça vous paraît ça vous
paraît trop strict comment faire par
exemple pour danser avec des
distanciation sociale alors est-ce que
ça me paraît trop stricte
oui et non parce que les discothèques
sur les lieux les plus contrôlées de
france ça il est utile de le rappeler
ensuite dansé avec distant avec des
distanciation je pense que ce sera pas
possible parce que ça va aller vers ce
même de l'adn
d'une discothèque par contre il est
certain et je martèle que anne était
sans discothèque c'est un été de tous
les dangers c'est à dire qu' il serait
utile de rajouter une corde à l'arc à
l'arc pour pouvoir lutter contre contre
le virus et contre l'insécurité car nos
milliers d'agents de sécurité ne seront
pas présents cet été si nous restons
ferme et 15 mois de fermeture j'imagine
que vous êtes vous avez pu réfléchir à
ces protocoles a notamment avec des
systèmes d'aération qui seront mises en
place oui alors bon ça nous fait ça nous
fait un peu sourire parce que il est
vrai que ces systèmes de ventilation on
nous en parle on nous propose de nous
les contrôler mais ces systèmes de
ventilation existe déjà dans toutes les
discothèques et ils sont déjà contrôlés
chaque année pour la lutte contre les
incendies et c'était déjà dispositif
qu'on avait mis en avant depuis 15 mois
c'est à dire qu'il soit aujourd'hui
sorti du tiroir pour être remis sur la
table c'est pas pour nous une sûr c'est
pas nous c'est pas une surprise donc
pour nous toutes là tout est réuni pour
que pour que les discothèques réouvre et
mettre un protocole trop stricte et how
a pas sanitaire en plus de cela ce
serait contre-productif et se serait
même inciter les jeunes à se rendre dans
nos pays voisins ou alors lors de fêtes
sauvages dans les fêtes sauvages dans
des soirées dans des rave parties etc
c'est très dangereux c'est
contre-productif je pense que c'est un
peu dur en même temps c'est à dire on
ressent vous rouvrir donc faut trouver
le juste équilibre pour que les
discothèques soit assez attractive et
pouvoir enlever ce caillou dans la
chaussure à nos élus locaux qui eux
seront au front en fait cet été c'est
eux qui vont être au front et qui vont
devoir essuyer tous les plâtres morgan
dalle il ya aussi un problème
d'inégalité comme les restaurateurs
d'ailleurs puisqu'il ya des discothèques
qui ont des détails plus petit que
d'autres si on impose une jauge est ce
que ce sera viable pour pour certaines
boîtes de nuit alors bon les inégalités
on y habituer au niveau des discothèques
vous savez surtout depuis 15 mois ça
fait 15 mois qu'on est con et stigmatisé
et discriminé
ensuite oui madame
lorsque
lorsqu'au bout de 15 mo vous n'êtes
toujours pas rouvert
on a un sentiment de discrimination et
surtout lorsque on entend notre ministre
de la santé nous émettre l'idée d'un
apas sanitaire hier sur une chaîne
concurrente
on se sent on se sent discriminé puisque
90% des discothèques ont une capacité
d'accueil de 300 personnes alors que
énormément de bamba ambiance musicale et
ram restaurants à ambiance musicale
peuvent accueillir autant de personnes
c'est à dire que en france il reste 1500
discothèque la grande majorité ont une
jauge ont une capacité d'accueil faible
et de nombreux restaurants bars ou salle
des fêtes eux ont des capacités
identique voire supérieure donc en
réalité c'est sa faux débat le mettre en
avant la capacité d'accueil des
discothèques parce que on se rend bien
compte que dans le paysage global des
déserts p il ya énormément de lieux qui
peuvent accueillir cette même capacité
et qui eux ne rompt tous et ce protocole
aussi stricte et peut-être un passé ni
terme à passer ni terre qui
juridiquement sera difficilement
défendable et économiquement également
très difficilement applicable merci
beaucoup morgan dalle de toutes ces
explications direct sur notre antenne ce
matin